[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour le total on va pas on va pas jouer
ici au théâtre mais on va proposer aux
enfants
on va enfin aux enfants un atelier de
parcours juste des aides dans le petit
jardin du théâtre de champ fleuri au
lieu hall est tout le temps événements
mais véro guadeloupe le talent pour
pratiquer le parcours là nous invite le
vêtement mais à venir à faire du
parcours avec nous vous n'en construit
belle ne doit pas de murs dans le petit
bassin pour le maïs haute est monté de
sangwa comme comme dans la magazine
c'est vraiment une grande expérience
parce qu'au début même quand on a
commencé devant le parvis ne n'aurais
jamais jamais pensé qu' un jaune ou de
sa jupe dans le théâtre et nous deux ça
fait ça justement nous deux ça fait ça
nous a fait une tournée dans tout dans
toute l'île est là aujourd'hui pour le
festival total et propose à nous d'aller
justement décentralisation mayotte
maurice pour le même grand événement
espace à mayotte pour les grands
événements hip hop évolution alors que
ça c'est un truc que l'équipe l'a
toujours voulu y participer et
maintenant participerez-vous nous fait
nous fait quoi ben mes amis non juste un
petit train pour vous dit le manager non
justement
un rêve surtout c'est vraiment qu'il est
possible
faut juste y croire quoi et foncer
foncer foncer façon plus devant on a
toujours être prêt pour gagner quoi
[Musique]
m
k